so I must admit that I uh have become
mildly allergic to the idea of
misinformation um it's one when talk
about disinformation which has a
technical uh definition as you know
State actors trying deliberately through
you know bot armies and so on to affect
public discourse and I I think was free
speech for individuals but not for BS um
so so I think there you can do something
misinformation um is this very very
Broad and vague term which covers um you
know things that
supposedly
um are wrong or misleading um but that
has been applied in its brief career to
things that turned out to be either
seriously worthy of consideration or
true one of the first areas in which
misinformation uh was was used to stifle
a debate was questions about the origin
of a CO virus um the so-call lab leak
theory was labeled as misinformation um
and not only the New York Times And The
Washington Post and saw not report on it
for a very long time but uh uh you know
C scientists were kicked off Facebook
and YouTube for talking about it I'm
still not sure if it's true but it is
now taken seriously as a possible or
perhaps even the most likely explanation
for the Orin of Co by uh you know very
serious institutions including most
intelligence agencies in United States
so I'm a little bit concerned about that
you know in the last
weeks uh the BBC and the New York Times
and CNN all spread uh the claim that
over 500 people had been killed by an
Israeli air strike at a hospital in Gaza
um uh you know with huge headlines with
push notifications and so on it turned
out not only that this was based on one
Claim by a uh doctor working for Hamas
but even on a apparently a
mistranslation of what that doctor said
he had talked about casualties which can
include injured as well as non-injured
people and of course it turned out that
according to um independent
investigations in uh uh uh newspapers as
well as the assessment of various secur
security agencies um very likely this
was a misfired rocket from Palestinian
Islamic Jihad in the Gaza Strip rather
than from Israel so who was spreading
the misinformation there um so so I I I
find that term a little bit concerning
but more broadly to the question of free
speech I think it is very important that
weight it not just for the laws of free
speech which are at threet in the United
Kingdom where um the criminal law has
become very Trigger Happy in finding and
sometimes jailing people for uh
offensive use um uh but more broadly a
culture of free speech and here we do
have to balance the freedom of
Association a core liberal value against
the attempt to push back against uh the
huge power that private companies now
have in regulating our lives and I think
that there's a few steps here the first
is to make it impossible for companies
to fire people for private political
views the second is to make it
impossible for companies to S to Ser a
business relationship with customers for
political reasons in particular
companies like Banks uh train companies
airline companies um basic internet
service providers that are required to
pursue basic functions of life you
should not be able toite boarding on a
plane and you should not be able to have
your bank account cancelled because of
your political views no matter how
offensive they might be but just not the
sort of um business that those companies
should be in making those judgments and
finally I think we need to push back
against some of the Hallmarks of quote
unquote cancel culture which go beyond
critical culture you should be very
skeptical about uh Collective letters uh
trying to sort of call for somebody's
head you should be very skeptical of
secondary boycotts that says unless you
stop associating with this person I'm
going to stop associating with you uh
these are elements of u a Culture of
Fear that's trying to impose uh
invisible lines as to where we can go
which people are free to engage in I'm
not talking in this respect about
government regulation against that
because that itself would interfere with
our freedom of Association but there are
forms of behavior that verse of us who
care about preserving a genuine culture
of freed spee should be very reluctant
to
engage